whether you want to be a web developer a
machine learning engineer or a data
scientist having a clear understanding
of data structures and algorithms is key
to acing your job interviews from
evaluating which data structure to use
when you're building on a website to
selecting the right algorithm for
analyzing user data every computer
science problem requires an intuitive
understanding of the tools you have at
your disposal companies don't hire
candidates who can just rattle off the
names of different data structures and
algorithms but instead the ones who can
choose the right approach to solving a
particular problem and provide a
rationale for their choice program will
enable you to excel at solving
everything from very well-defined
problems like how to calculate the
efficiency of a specific algorithm to
more open-ended problems like building
your own private blockchain or writing a
web crawler whether you're new to the
ideas surrounding data structures and
algorithms or just looking to refresh in
a few concepts before your next
interview this program will provide you
with a wealth of valuable practice and
resources throughout the program you'll
have a dedicated mentor who will support
you with one-on-one guidance and help
you solidify your understanding of these
exciting topics join the data structures
and algorithms nano degree programs
today and you will get to work on over
100 exercises and real-world projects
learn how to approach open-ended
problems and design and implement your
solution this nano degree program will
prepare you for your next coding
interview to launch your career as a
software engineer
[Music]